to talk about that please come here
alright Vanderpump rules coming back oh
my gosh this is just like old times I
love it
we're not ready you're not ready the
first episode you like and then you just
get sucked in I think we should just
break the [ __ ] up what's your one word
to describe the season
scandalous disastrous Jesus Christ when
I say - it's a really jcu season one
word disturbing don't take crazy insane
or dramatic I can't use those words in
her house anymore she's banned those
words it's chaotic chaotic utter chaos
it's my birthday get off your high horse
girl did you really just say it learn
your place [ __ ] it's naughty but
it's funny I think the stakes are higher
because they've grown up a bit and so
they're not slippin but it's a lot of
fun we're getting older our dynamics are
changing some people are chilling out
and some people are going back to their
crazy antics we have a lot of former
villains getting back in touch with
their roots crazy Kristen likes it -
once in a while line sexy
mostly jackets to filter out I'm always
everyone's bag you have me of the
resignation you're gonna have to watch
and see
[Music]